And of course, again, we'll do this as a quiz so, my first question for you
regarding the first success-factor is this.
In this line here, when we pick a random (0, 1) assignment for the variables
how many variables can  we expect to get right on average?
By right, I mean, if in a satisfying assignment the variable is set to false,
then this random assignment here also sets it to false and if it needs to be set to true
this random assignment here also sets it to true.
So, my three choices for you here are the following:
Can we expect to nearly get all the variables correct in this random assignment here?
Can we expect to get about half the variables correct in this random assignment here?
Or is it not possible to make a statement about this here?